alors mes chers collègues
un peu plus de deux mois après leur
audition par notre mission conjointe de
contrôle nous recevons à nouveau
monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires et Madame Dominique
Faure ministre délégué chargé des
collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité monsieur le ministre Béchu vous
avez
hérité du précédent gouvernement ce
dossier brûlant d'usane lors de votre
prise de fonction en juillet dernier
c'est votre prédécesseur madame wargon
qui avait piloté la naissance du zan et
défendue ce volet de la loi climat
résilience qui nous donne quand même un
volet assez rude et assez sous certains
aspects même dogmatiques qui aujourd'hui
nouveau de nous retrouver au travers de
cet exercice de la commission spéciale
aujourd'hui alors vous rappelez souvent
comme la semaine dernière au Sénat lors
la question au gouvernement que vous
n'êtes pas à l'origine du zan
contrairement à nous parlementaire qui
avons voté cette loi alors à ce renvoi
de balle qui me semble un peu facile je
souhaiterais quand même en préambule à
cette audition vous répondre en trois
points d'abord je rappelle que le zan
politique au combien structurante a été
introduites à dessin dans un texte
fleuve en patchwork dénué d'études
d'impact sérieuse il y en a pas eu très
peu la loi climat résilience qui
comptait bien d'autres sujets rénovation
énergétiques ZFE et bien d'autres nous
l'avons voté en responsabilité car nous
soutenons l'ambition écologique de la
France mais ce vote évidemment n'est pas
un chèque en blanc sur l'ensemble de ces
dispositions encore moins sur le zan et
par ailleurs vous le savez bien monsieur
le ministre dans le cadre de la navette
parlementaire des initiatives du Sénat
telles que par exemple la sortie du
comte foncier des projets d'intérêt
nationaux avaient adopté au Sénat et
puis ils sont sortis dans le cadre de la
navette parlementaire et pourtant nous
avons voté au bout du bout l'entièreté
de la loi climat résilience ensuite vous
n'êtes pas sans ignorer la position du
Sénat au sujet des décrets
d'applications qui ont en partie des
voyelles l'esprit de la loi que nous
avons voté dans la loi nous n'avons pas
fait du stradet un super Scott ce sont
les décrets d'avril 2022 écrit par le
gouvernement qui ont durci le zen dans
la loi nous avions demandé au
gouvernement de fixer rapidement par
décret la maille d'observation de
l'artificialisation pour permettre aux
collectivités de se mettre au travail
c'est ceux ils ne sont toujours pas
fixées et la nomenclature est à ce stade
un satisfaisante je pense que l'on peut
donc dire sans exagération que la loi
que nous avons votée n'est pas celle que
le gouvernement veut faire appliquer au
jourduit nous sommes donc en droit à
Monsieur le Ministre d'être critique sur
l'application actuelle même si nous
avons voté cette loi c'est la pleinement
notre rôle de contrôle de l'action du
gouvernement enfin certes vous n'étiez
pas ministre lors de la naissance du zen
mais il ne faut pas pour autant sans
laver les mains nous avons un intérêt
commun par le menteur et gouvernement en
responsabilité à faciliter son
déploiement je pense que vous partagez
ça monsieur le ministre au sein des
territoires le zan est aujourd'hui
l'inquiétude numéro un des maires et de
nombreux obstacles sont sur le chemin
l'État ne peut pas s'en désintéresser il
faut fournir soutien accompagnement
ingénierie financement et comme nous le
proposons ajustement législatif lorsque
ces pertinent car aujourd'hui c'est bien
l'architecture du zinc qui nous motive
et qui nous réunit au travers de la
réflexion sur cette proposition de loi
vous nous aviez dit il y a quelques mois
que vous étiez prêt à retenir la
proposition législative du Sénat comme
véhicule d'adaptation du âmes maintenant
que ce texte est déposé j'espère avec
mes collègues que votre état d'esprit
n'a pas changé et que vous soutiendrez
notre initiative monsieur le ministre
les collectivités attendent depuis de
longs mois un geste de votre part le
temps est venu de leur envoyer un signal
positif et des réponses concrètes madame
la ministre fort vous êtes au sein du
gouvernement l'interlocutrice
privilégiée des collectivités
territoriales vous êtes aussi
spécifiquement chargé de la ruralité
avec ses spécificités que nous sommes
connaissons bien ici au Sénat vous
n'ignorez pas les lourds enjeux de
cohésion de réduction des inégalités
territoriales et de développement rural
et à ce titre nous nous étonnons que
l'approche très centralisée et
descendante du Zen bien que tempérée par
des amendements du Sénat n'est pas été
accompagnée de mesures spécifiques à la
ruralité vous aviez évoqué il y a
quelques trouver une garantie rurale
dont les contours étaient encore floues
il nous semble que c'est maintenant
qu'il faut avancer sur ces sujets avant
que le coût ne soit parti et que l'on ne
sent mort de les doigts dans 5 ou 10 ans
monsieur le ministre madame la ministre
l'heure de votre dernier audition devant
cette assemblée nous avions demandé
quelles actions vous entendiez prendre
pour faciliter la mise en oeuvre du zan
sans qu'aucune évolution législative ou
réglementaire soit intervenues à ce
stade d'au moins plus tard le Sénat a
pris le devant et a présenté un texte de
loi pluripartisant contenant des mesures
concrètes c'est sur celle-ci que nous
souhaitons vous entendre aujourd'hui
pour recueillir votre analyse mesure par
mesure l'enjeu de cette audition est
simple comment pourrons-nous avancer
ensemble pour faire aboutir un texte
facilitateur et constructif sur Lausanne
qui répondent aux attentes concrètes des
collectivités territoriales quelles
mesures pourrez-vous soutenir et quelle
mesure vous paraissent de voir être
ajustée nous savons que les députés de
l'Assemblée nationale se sont aussi
saisis du sujet en lien avec votre
gouvernement au sein d'un groupe de
travail chargé de formuler des
propositions d'évolution du zan pourtant
le temps presse et le calendrier du
année serré j'espère que les travaux de
l'Assemblée ne vous empêcheront pas de
considérer avec sérieux le texte issu du
Sénat qui s'appuie sur de nombreux mois
de travaux approfondis et l'expérience
des élus locaux de toute région et de
l'inscrire à l'Assemblée nationale afin
que la navette se poursuive je laisse
sans plus attendre la parole à notre
rapporteur Jean-Baptiste blanc qui va
vous interroger plus précisément sur les
mesures portées par la proposition de
loi et puis nous vous cédons évidemment
la parole pour un propos liminaire enfin
nos collègues vous adresseront leurs
questions merci d'avoir bien voulu
écouter ce propos liminaire et monsieur
le rapporteur vous avez la parole sans
plus attendre merci
merci madame la Présidente et chère
Valérie madame est la ministre monsieur
le ministre je souhaiterais évoquer avec
vous et en présence de la commission
spéciale plus précisément certaines des
mesures de la proposition de loi
sénatoriale
donc monsieur le ministre Christophe
béchule le décret d'application d'avril
dernier est allé à la rencontre de
l'esprit de la loi climat céliance tel
qu'elle a été votée par le Parlement en
prévoyant le recours obligatoire aux
règles du fascicule de stradettes
c'est-à-dire un fort degré de contrainte
et des collectivités l'article 2 de la
proposition de loi sénatoriale prévoit
un retour à l'esprit de la loi avec un
rapport de prise en compte entre les
documents locaux et le stradet nous
entendons en parallèle à renforcer le
pilotage du zan avec une conférence
régionale de gouvernance qui effectuera
un suivi régulier des trajectoires dans
ces conditions
le gouvernement entendra-t-il l'appel à
la souplesse qui émane des collectivités
et qui émanent de notre commission ou
persistez-vous à vouloir prendre des
documents à vouloir faire des documents
régionaux des superscots normatifs à
l'encontre de la répartition des
compétences des centralisées en matière
d'urbanisme monsieur le ministre nous
auditions et analyse dans le cadre de la
mission conjoint de contrôle notamment
confirmé qu'il était intenable de faire
porter sur l'enveloppe
d'artificialisation d'une région et des
collectivités de son ressort la
superficie des grands projets situés sur
son territoire c'est pourquoi notre
proposition de loi Formule 2
propositions concernant les grands
projets à l'article 4 d'abord les
compter à part au sein d'une enveloppe
nationale et ensuite ne pas les inclure
dans les objectifs de réduction de
l'artificialisation du zan de nos
précédents échanges
il ressort que vous êtes défavorable à
cette solution à laquelle vous
privilégiez une mutualisation nationale
ma question est donc premièrement votre
solution de mutualisation est-elle
vraiment équitable notamment pour les
régions qui ne portent pas de grands
projets qui ne bénéficieront pas de
retomber économique mais qui devront
mutualiser leur fonciers deuxièmement
est-ce que tout cela est réaliste si
l'enveloppe pour la deuxième période
n'était plus de 120 000 hectares mais de
60000 les grands projets consommeraient
un tiers des droits à construire
autorisés en 2050 une faudra atteindre
le 0 artificialisation net cela ne
sonnera-t-il pas à la fin des grands
projets car même mutualiser nous
pourront jamais être compensés par une
renaturation équivalente sauf à ce que
rien d'autre soit construit en France
pendant 10 ans concrètement comment
pouvons-nous encore réaliser des grands
projets en 2050 madame la ministre nous
savons que vous avez été alerté à de
nombreuses reprises par les élus des
territoires ruraux sur le sort qui sera
le leur sur le régime du zan s'attendons
toujours d'en savoir plus sur la
garantie rurale annoncé par le
gouvernement il y a plusieurs mois le
Sénat donc formulé une solution simple à
l'article 7 que toutes les communes
puissent disposer d'une enveloppe
minimale c'est-à-dire que la
territorialisation ne puisse pas priver
complètement une commune de possibilités
de construction nous avons souhaité la
fixer à un hectare nous savons que le
gouvernement est opposé cette
proposition mais serait ouvert à un
plancher correspondant à 1 % de la
surface artificielle de la commune pour
vous nous indiquer le nombre de communes
qui seraient effectivement protégées si
l'on retenait ce 1% pour éviter que ce
1% ne soit plus favorable aux communes
ayant beaucoup artificialisé par le
passé souhaiteriez-vous la réserver
uniquement à certaines communes et si
oui lesquelles comment éviter les les
effets de seuil cache pas que je suis
plutôt déçu des échanges avec la DHP sur
le sujet encore tout à l'heure voilà
incapable de répondre sur ce sujet
simple nous avons dit que nous
auditionnons de nouveau et on vous en
remercie on n'a jamais autant vu de
ministres sur le sujet vraiment c'est
très précieux évidemment t'attends
toujours des éléments sur le 1% voilà
n'ont pas été capable de nous répondre
je le dis comme je le pense voilà
logiquement vous voulez vous avancer
dans ces dans ces conditions un hectare
en pour cent tout se discute et encore
faut-il avoir les éléments
bref madame alaministre que pensez-vous
de la proposition formulée par le Sénat
à l'article 8 qui vise admettre en
réserve une partie de l'enveloppe
régional ou du Scott au profit des
projets d'intérêt supracommunal afin de
permettre aux petites communes ou à la
ruralité de porter des projets communs
quel autre solution voyez-vous pour que
les projets intercommunaux puissent se
réaliser surtout dans les communes non
couvertes par un pluie le tout semble
mettre en péril les solidarités
territoriales enfin Madame la Ministre
un article 12 nous proposons deux outils
très concrets pour que les mers puissent
gérer plus facilement la transition vers
le zanne et piloter la consommation de
fonciers donc le Sourcier est statué le
droit de préemption
quels outils qu'est-ce que cela
suscite chez vous comme commentaire mais
je crois que vous êtes plutôt favorable
et quelle dispositif d'ingénierie par
ailleurs et quels nouveaux outils tout
court le gouvernement entendit de mettre
en place pour combler les manques et
accompagner les collectivités pour le
zan avant de vous remercier de vous
laisser la parole et de prendre des
questions de nos collègues comme notre
présidente souhaite évidemment que que
ce travail puisse cheminer et je
m'interroge enfin à ce titre sur un
article du jour ou qui fait état d'une
PPL de Monsieur Bastien Marchive
apparenté Renaissance qui va présenter
demain une PPL sur le sujet à
l'Assemblée nationale alors quel est
l'intérêt de savoir cet après-midi si
demain tout est réglé à l'Assemblée
nationale voilà alors est-ce qu'on est
toujours dans une phase d'entente
cordiale en vue de rechercher un
objectif d'intérêt commun et dans le
cadre d'un sujet qui préoccupe tous les
sénateurs sur tous les bancs ou pas
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre après cette longue série de
questions vous avez la parole et on vous
écoute religieusement très bien mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
présidente monsieur le rapporteur
puisque vous avez décidé de
placer vos propos liminaires l'un et
l'autre à la fois sur le temps de la
franchise je vais vous répondre
exactement de la même manière
d'abord ça nous permettra d'aller au
fond et de profiter au mieux des moments
qui sont devant nous
ce sujet depuis le milieu du mois de
juillet j'ai eu des occasions non
seulement de m'exprimer sur le sujet
mais de joindre les gestes à la parole
et d'avoir de multiples temps de
rencontre plus ou moins officiel avec
les uns et les autres
ça a commencé avec une question
gouvernement mi-juillet ça s'est
prolongé contenu des échanges que j'ai
eu avec les sénateurs avec la suspension
des décrets le 6 août ça a repris le 29
août avec une visio avec la présidente
Sophie prima qui était même à l'étranger
ce jour-là pour autant que je m'en
souvienne et avec un groupe partenarial
au cours duquel fin août j'ai indiqué
que non seulement nous étions prêt à les
bouger mais que comme dans les remarques
qui remontaient il n'y avait pas que des
éléments qui étaient d'ordre
réglementaires il faudrait une évolution
législative et depuis le mois de
septembre la position que j'ai exprimée
était que il était légitime que cette
proposition puisse venir d'une PPL
sénatoriale à la fois pour refléter ce
qui avait été votre écho et votre
résonance à ce qui se disait sur le
terrain et que pour que puisse
précisément compte tenu de ce lien
étroit qui existe dans cette chambre que
je connais un peu et dont je garde des
souvenirs émus
puisse permettre d'avoir une expression
juste
de la vision du Sénat sur les éléments
qui devaient bouger
et au mois de décembre je vous ai
annoncé que la majorité relative à
l'Assemblée nationale ne souhaitant pas
que le débat n'ait lieu
qu'au Sénat déposerait une proposition
de loi
de manière à préciser ce qui était ses
lignes à elle pour en quelque sorte
pouvoir entamer une sorte de CMP virtuel
en ayant une idée de ce qui était les
points de compromis sur lequel il y
avait déjà des accords entre l'Assemblée
et le Sénat sans remettre en cause le
processus qui consiste à avoir un
véhicule législatif qui commence par le
Sénat je vous ai tenu ses propos au mois
de décembre je vous les ai retenu au
mois de janvier je vous ai même donné
les noms de ceux qui étaient
susceptibles de déposer ses propositions
d'or donc ne voyez pas ce qui se passe
demain comme étant un télescopage de
calendrier mais comme étant la suite au
contraire d'un dialogue dans lequel le
gouvernement fait le choix de la
co-construction en disant ça peut venir
du Sénat de manière transpartisane mais
de la même manière que le bicamérisme
suppose de respecter la chambre haute je
ne vois pas en quoi on pourrait dénier à
la chambre basse de se préoccuper de ce
sujet de cette question et d'exprimer un
certain nombre de propositions et de
préférence ça c'est pour poser le cadre
pour que les choses soient
extrêmement clair
ensuite
faire de la politique c'est par
définition c'est forcé le mieux possible
de tenir compte du présent de préserver
l'avenir et en ayant systématiquement au
cœur à la fois le souci de ce qui
s'exprime le moins facilement de ce
qu'on le moins facilement accès aux
médias et puis de l'intérêt général pour
autant qu'on puisse le comprendre il y a
peu de propositions autant que la lutte
contre l'étalement urbain qui réunit
tout ça avec évidemment la difficulté de
trouver un équilibre entre ce présent
ces avenir que nous ne connaissons pas
et un certain nombre de choses que nous
connaissons déjà personne ici et c'est
le procès que je ne ferai à personne
ne pense que l'étalement urbain n'est
pas un sujet et que on n'a pas été trop
loin à une certaine époque de notre
histoire on a atteint les 60 000
hectares par an d'artificialisation dans
les années 70 et on a ensuite avec un
certain nombre de textes et de loi fait
en sorte de diminuer ces niveaux de
consommation je reprends pas les
différents textes qu'on peut être faits
mais ça a été à la fois et dans toutes
les majorités qui se sont succédées
globalement depuis le début de l'année
2000 des préoccupations compris des
formes diverses et on est arrivé à un
niveau moyen de consommation de l'ordre
de 20 000 hectares au cours de ces
dernières années la loi climat et
résilience
qui effectivement
moi je me présente ce soir devant vous
au côté de Dominique Faure
d'abord pour vous confirmer de la façon
la plus solennelle qui soit que cette
proposition de loi nous la regardons pas
comme un objet sénatorial mais comme le
début d'une évolution de la loi sur le
zéro artificialisation net
et comme étant le véhicule par lequel le
texte pourrait bouger je l'ai dit de
multiples je le redis ce soir et en
étant entendu ce soir devant cette
commission spéciale je profite pour le
préciser mais pas avec le souci qui est
une PPL qui soit adopté en mars ou en
avril à quelques mois des élections
sénatoriales pour montrer que la chambre
haute se soucie de ces grands électeurs
avec le souci que ça devienne la loi et
donc à l'issue de sa sortie du Sénat il
y a une capacité dans une commission
mixte paritaire à faire en sorte que les
points d'évolution législatives
aboutissent pas qu'on est un constat
d'une difficulté avancée entre les deux
sujets et donc à partir de ce moment-là
ce que je souhaite c'est que les
conditions de ce dialogue et la claire
conscience à la fois des axes sur
lesquels ça peut bouger et des points
sur lequel il y a des réserves ou des
réticences ou au sein du gouvernement ou
que nous pressentons demain au sein de
l'Assemblée nationale et qui pourrait
compromettre l'aboutissement du travail
tel que vous souhaitez soit clair pour
tout le monde
je vais me livrer à la réponse
aux questions qui ont été adressées et à
Dominique Faure et à moi sur les
différents articles de manière liminaire
pour que vous ayez notre position
commune parce que sur ce sujet il n'y a
pas entre nous d'écart et de position
elle est tout autant la ministre
des collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité que je suis celui de la
cohésion des territoires et sa
préoccupation de ce qu'est la
perspective de transition écologique et
la durabilité de ce déploiement est
aussi présente dans son cœur et dans
l'action qui était la sienne comme mère
avant de rentrer au gouvernement qu'elle
était dans la mienne dans des fonctions
qui étaient similaires
votre texte il comprend beaucoup
d'avancées
je commence par ça parce que c'est
globalement la vision que nous avons
d'abord il corrige un certain nombre
d'erreurs je reviens pas sur le fait que
le solde puisse s'appliquer des 2020 il
a le mérite de proposer des outils
nouveaux pour que les collectivités
locales puissent le mettre en oeuvre de
manière effective il pointe des sujets
sur lequel vous précisez ce que le
gouvernement aurait affaire pour rendre
le dispositif applicable je pense à la
délivrance de données et vous avez
soulevé pour le coup c'était dans un
cadre d'une mission flash ou d'un
rapport que Jean-Baptiste Blanc avait
commis seul sur les questions de
fiscalité quelques angles morts qui
n'ont pas été directement tradés dans
celui-là mais qui pourrait ou dans le
cadre de la navette ou plus
vraisemblablement dans le cadre d'une
réflexion qui aboutirait des mesures
dans le cadre du PLF nous permettent de
compléter utilement ce qu'est cet objet
qui est d'abord juridique
depuis le 1er jusqu'au dernier article
on a environ la moitié des articles sur
lesquels on n'a pas de difficultés on en
a quelques-uns pour lequel nous avons
des interrogations sur la manière dont
les choses sont écrites et on a quelques
autres qui nous posent des difficultés
plus ou moins fortes par rapport à leur
perspective
l'ajustement des délais par lequel vous
commencez
j'allais dire que chaque jour qui passe
la sagesse voudrait qu'on soit capable
de faire un bouger sur la date à
laquelle les choses se mettent en œuvre
il y a plusieurs manières de procéder il
y a ceux qui pensent qu'il faut que la
durée initiale ne soit plus 10 mais 12
ans il y a ceux qui considèrent au
contraire qu'il faut garder une période
de 10 ans mais avec une date de
démarrage différé je pense que sur ces
sujets là trouver des compromis qui nous
permettent de nous retrouver et de faire
en sorte de retrouver un temps pour le
dialogue ne sera sans doute pas la chose
la plus complexe
l'article 2 il est très clairement
le premier dans l'ordre à nous poser une
difficulté parce que s'il n'y a pas de
trajectoire qui soit prescriptive à ce
moment là il n'y a aucune garantie que
nous atteindrons les objectifs
la France est le pays qui compte
l'artificialisation rapportée à sa
population la plus élevée d'Europe
un hectare c'est entre 190 et 290 tonnes
de CO2 stockés quand c'est un espace
naturel ou agricole à l'inverse quand
cet artificialisé non seulement ça ne
stocke pas de CO2 en termes de lutte
contre les règlements climatiques mais
ça participe à une accentuation du
dérèglement j'ajoute que y compris par
rapport à ce que vous évoquez sur le
fait de pouvoir préserver notre
souveraineté dans le monde qui arrive
préserver ces hectares pour qu'on puisse
faire en sorte de préserver une
souveraineté alimentaire est un sujet
que je sais partager par beaucoup ici
vous soulevez dans les dans les
perspectives qui arrivent un angle mort
qui finalement n'est pas évoqué dans
votre PPL mais que je vais
volontairement évoquer et qui se
retrouve à l'appui de l'article 4 sur
les grands projets d'envergure nationale
ce point là il est crucial à plein des
gares d'abord si nous conservons un
dispositif tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui
la charge de ces grands projets sera
répartie d'une manière qui sera
différente en fonction des territoires
selon la nature de ces grands projets et
nous ne trouvons pas sa juste j'assume
je ne trouve pas ça juste parce que
certains de ces projets y concourent pas
seulement à la région qui les accueille
je pense par exemple à cette Nord Europe
qui va profiter à des régions
périphériques avec une trajectoire
d'artificialisation et de décarbonation
des moyens de transport qu'il faudrait
quand même pas bloquer au nom du zan
alors que les objectifs sont comparables
et ils permettra de soulager la région
Normandie ils permettra de soulager plus
largement en réorganisant une partie de
la chaîne logistique d'autres
territoires
puis si vous allez du côté de
l'Occitanie indépendamment de ce que
chacun peut penser des projets de LGV
penser que les LGV qui ont eu lieu par
le passé donnent des droits nouveaux
artificialisation puisque elles sont
intégrées dans la calcul de
l'artificialisation antérieure qui
permet d'avoir la division par deux du
nombre d'hectares autorisé et qu'à
l'inverse ce qu'on attendu qui n'ont pas
eu les enclavant et qui n'ont pas eu les
projets ils auraient non seulement la
tente mais en plus le fait que
maintenant on leur prendrait la totalité
de l'espace sur des trajectoires qui ont
été un moindries par le fait qu'il n'y
avait pas de grands projets dans le
stock c'est une forme de double peine
qui nous semble pas juste
je vous le dis comme je le pense
la somme des grands projets je ne vois
pas comment elle atteindrait d'alsom des
grands projets théoriques compte tenu
des durées moyennes de réalisation des
grands projets d'envergure national me
semble très optimiste et ambitieuse
comme souvent d'ailleurs dans beaucoup
de documents de programmation et donc il
faudra veiller parce que la
mutualisation ou le comté à part ne
prennent pas pour acquis que toutes ces
grands projets d'envergure national
soient réalisés en temps en heure et à
date parce que sinon ça provoquera une
sorte de mouvement de réduction qui sera
supérieur à ce que la réalité nous
conduira à avoir je le glisse avant de
revenir au cœur du sujet
trois éléments sur les grands projets
d'envergure National 1 quels sont-ils
nous plaidons pour que ce soit une liste
qui ne soit pas trop exhaustive et qu'on
n'entre pas dans des usines à gaz qui
consisterait à penser qu'à la fin
n'importe quel projet du moment qu'il
est de l'ordre de l'État devient un
grand projet d'envergure national je ne
dis pas que c'est la tentation mais dès
lors que la discussion va commencer
qu'on va commencer à discuter et je
pense que le caractère limitatif de ces
grands projets Estables avec des choses
qui sont évidentes avec d'autres qui
sont discutables 2 nous ne souhaitons
pas que les projets qui ne sont pas
d'initiatives nationales soient
considérées comme des grands projets
d'envergure nationale et je pense très
clairement en disant ça à des projets
industriels qui s'y relevaient de cette
conception conduirait à ce que pour
bénéficier du tiret à part il y a une
autorisation administrative qui soit
donnée ce qu'il faut serait la
décentralisation d'un point de vue
économique
et si vous allez au bout du processus
que vous imaginez que du coup on peut
donner le label pour être compté à part
ça veut bien dire qu'il y aura un moment
un acte gouvernemental qui lui donnera
cette caractéristique et qui conduira à
devoir arbitrer entre ce que des régions
feraient pour attirer des projets
économiques sous cet angle là ça me pose
une première difficulté sous le deuxième
c'est à partir de quand un projet
économique
est considéré comme étant d'envergure
national
et là on a un deuxième angle mort qui
est le fait d'avoir potentiellement des
débats sans fin du contentieux et dans
quelque chose qui irait à l'encontre de
la volonté de pouvoir accélérer sur un
certain nombre de sujets 3
si ça sort de la trajectoire
d'artificialisation la tentation des
deux premiers points devient d'autant
plus forte si quand c'est un projet
local ça consomme du foncier un projet
national ça non consomme pas tout le
monde demandera à être considéré en
National de manière à pouvoir limiter
les conséquences sur les trajectoires
on a un débat qui se focalise autour du
point d'arrivée et qui ne regarde pas le
chemin
tout le monde est obnubilé par le fait
qu'on va vers le zéro personne ne
regarde ce que veut dire une trajectoire
de division par deux dans les années qui
viennent compte tenu à la fois du stock
des tendances sur lesquelles nous sommes
et surtout je le dis
de l'angle mort qui fait que personne ne
discute de ce qui se passe entre 2031 et
et permettez-moi de vous dire que ce
débat là en nombre d'hectares il est
autrement plus important de savoir ce
que nous faisons des grands projets
d'envergure national sur la partie 2021
et de ce point de vue les interrogations
du rapporteur sur il se passe quoi après
au-delà de la période dans laquelle nous
entrons elle me semble juste et tant
qu'à définir des trajectoires la
question de se poser sur où nous allons
après ne serait pas forcément absurde et
c'est une réflexion aux personnes de ces
saisies
pourquoi je dis ça parce que sur les
années qui viennent si on est sur 12500
hectares d'urbanisation
d'artificialisation en moyenne or
renaturation
il faut pas oublier qu'on a un stock de
200 000 hectares de friches
qui représentent à lui seul l'équivalent
de ce qu'on a artificialisé depuis 10
ans donc on a en fait une décennie
gratuite
d'artificialisation autour de ces stocks
auxquels on ajoute une trajectoire qui
est plus que la moitié de ces dernières
années puisque c'est la moyenne des dix
dernières années alors qu'on était déjà
dans une tendance à la sobriété
ensuite on arrive sur la garantie rurale
cette garantie rurale nous avons entendu
ce que le Sénat a dit la première
ministre a une expression forte je vous
ai dit que nous étions disposés à le
faire Dominique force est engagé devant
un certain nombre d'associations d'élus
et le point d'arrivée il est comparable
en nombre d'hectares il diffère sur le
mode de calcul
je suis passablement agacé si les
éléments que je vous ai donnés oralement
ne vous ont pas été distribués
par mes services
et je m'engage à ce que ces éléments ne
voulaient pas vous les fassions passer
délicieux de cette audition
pour être clair il y a à la minute où
nous nous parlons des modes de calcul en
fonction de ce pourcent qui ne dépendent
que d'une chose c'est du fait de savoir
si cette garantie de 1% de l'applique à
toutes les communes de France ou si on
l'applique aux communes rurales et si on
l'applique aux rurales quelle est la
porte d'entrée que nous retenons est-ce
que ce sont les noms d'habitants est-ce
que c'est la densité et vous avez sur
une page 7 ou 8 modes de calcul
différents qui permettent de savoir
quand une commune sont concernées
combien d'hectares sont concernés
permettant de débouler tout ça il me
semblait que la consigne de vous passez
ces éléments vous avez été donnés et
donc je déplore que ce ne soit pas le
cas je vais oralement vous donner les
trois principaux chiffres et tout le
reste votre commission spéciale en
disposera
globalement
1% des surfaces urbanisées en France ça
correspond à 3611 hectares il y a 36000
communes auxquelles vous donnez un
hectare vous êtes sur des données qui
sont comparables ce qui diffèrent c'est
évidemment ensuite la manière d'aller
répartir ces hectares
pour vous donner un autre chiffre il y a
798 communes en France
qui n'ont pas artificialisé un mètre
carré depuis 15 ans qui sont des facto
en 0 artificialisation nette quand on
regarde les chiffres de ces dernières
pour plein de raisons certaines parce
qu'elles sont uniquement en zone
inondables d'autres parce qu'elles sont
cernés par des AOC d'autres peut-être
parce qu'il y a pas eu de projets mais
ça permet d'avoir quelques éléments si
je reprends
si nous prenons uniquement les communes
peu denses au sens de l'Insee
qui correspond à une définition sur
laquelle on peut s'accorder au titre de
la ruralité même s'il peut y avoir des
biais mais imaginons qu'on prenne peu
dense ça donne
18 000 hectares
en appliquant le 1%
. si nous appliquons les communes très
peu denses ça baisse très fort puisqu'on
tombe à
4000 hectares mais il convient
d'additionner les très peu denses et les
peu denses pour avoir une idée à ce
moment là du bloc rural et on est aux
alentours de 22000 hectares pour vous
donner un ordre de grandeur de ce que
donne le 1% et après on peut continuer
puisque une des subtilités ou des
discussions c'est est-ce que cette
garantie rurale est subordonnée au fait
d'avoir des documents d'urbanisme est-ce
que c'est subordonné au fait d'être dans
un plus est-ce que c'est subordonné au
fait d'avoir une carte communale ou
est-ce que ça s'applique sans limite
l'application sans limite ce sont les
chiffres que je vous donne et ensuite
vous aurez les chiffres si on décide
d'avoir des portes à l'entrée qui
dépendent du type de documents dont on
discute
voilà pour les éléments
chiffrés qui vous seront remis dans
quelques instants
sur la création de la retenue Scott
pluie
ça existe je une collectivité peut
d'ores et déjà décidé de le mettre en
œuvre sans ajouter de façon spécifique
se dispositif
je ne sais pas l'intérêt qu'il y a à
préciser que c'est une faculté ou une
possibilité parce que j'ai le sentiment
que ça peut ajouter une couche de
complexité mais d'un autre côté ça peut
aussi conduire certains élus avoir des
idées on n'a aucune opposition principe
mais pour nous cette possibilité d'avoir
une réserve pour des projets d'une
certaine importance sur le plan
intercommunal elle existe déjà dans les
textes sans avoir besoin d'être précisé
donc on n'a pas de difficultés par
rapport aux dispositif enfin je vous ai
dit et je le redis ce soir devant cette
commission spéciale tout l'intérêt que
nous portons aux droits de préemption au
sursis à statuer que vous imaginez que
vous ajoutez dans le dispositif et aux
obligations de délivrance de données
avec une interrogation et sur les pas de
temps et sur la maille à laquelle il
conviendrait de les transférer pour
aller aussi vite que possible et pour
répondre aux principales questions et
Dominique me pardonnera de l'avoir fait
pour nous deux on se répartir ensuite
les questions mais ça me semblait être
l'occasion de vous exprimer une position
commune sur ces différents sujets
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre je
vous propose sans plus attendre de
laisser la parole à mes collègues en
commençant par Cécile Cu Karman oui
merci madame la présidente madame
monsieur le ministre
j'oserai dire
vous savez vendredi dernier il y avait
les Victoires de la Musique et un
chanteur triplement récompensé à une
chanson assez célèbre qui régulièrement
répète basique simple et je crois que
finalement la vie politique c'est aussi
cela il y a à la fois du basique dans ce
que vous dites effectivement vous n'êtes
pas forcément
comptable de ce qui a pu être voté
précédemment mais c'est assez simple
tout de même de se dire qu'il n'y a pas
eu de changement de majorité et que donc
vous allez être tout de même les
héritiers je crois qu'il est aussi assez
basique de se dire
et j'ai entendu et je ne veux pas
concret de polémique
il y a deux façons de voir l'histoire
soit effectivement de se dire que
élection sénatoriale arrivant une PPL
peut être déposée une autre pourrait
être de se dire que le calendrier imposé
par la loi votée initialement impose au
parlementaire que nous sommes de déposer
dans ce délits qui nous est imposé cette
proposition de loi
moi je veux revenir sur trois exemples
la première je l'évoquais précédemment
j'étais vendredi midi à l'inauguration
dans un centre bourg commune de un peu
plus de 1000 habitants
j'ai envie de vous dire ce qui
aujourd'hui répondrait à tous les
standards de ce que l'on peut attendre
tout d'abord plus de 12 ans de
requalification du tannement foncier en
plein centre bourg pour une opération
qui bien évidemment sur un terrain nu
aurait un an et demi des difficultés
inévitablement financière donc je sais
vous allez me répondre il y a une
fonderie et de mal fond vert mais comme
on l'a tous déjà distribué 50 fois dans
chaque département à un moment donné ça
va devenir limité mais au-delà de la
question du financement surtout problème
d'ingénierie problème de délai problème
de disponibilité et donc finalement ces
projets là si vertueux soient-ils ne
sont qu'une partie émergée de l'iceberg
et qui pose en tout cas de gros soucis
sur tout le reste des communes parce que
toutes les communes n'ont pas ces
opportunités tout d'abord foncières et
ses capacités à faire deuxième exemple
il y a un peu plus de 6 mois j'arrive
dans une commune ça va certainement vous
faire sourire
un maire une commune de 5000 habitants
me dit écoute Cécile j'ai un souci
avant 2017 j'étais dans une communauté
de communes
et depuis 2017 je suis passée par la loi
notre et et là monsieur le ministre en
tout cas on pourrait pas me dire le
contraire puisque à l'époque dans la
majorité centrale vous l'avez voté me
semble-t-il et je crois mon souvenir je
suis donc depuis la loi notre passé dans
une communauté d'agglomération dès lors
la loi srue s'impose à moi et je n'ai
pas le pourcentage requis de logements
social et donc puisque la vie c'est
comme je le disais vas-y coussin soit on
réécrit tout de cette loi sont l'adapte
et donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait de ces
communes qui vont devoir demain
continuer
de construire du logement social les
unes pour satisfaire les besoins habitat
les autres pour ne pas être sanctionnés
et pénalisés on va pas ouvrir ici des
voies sur la loi séru bon ça il joue
aucun totem je pense que la loi serrure
elle vit à la vécu une forme de courbe
de gauche qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans un plafond et que si on ne fait
rien ça va s'effondrer alors que
l'objectif d'une politique publique
c'est de continuer de progresser donc
certains la supprimer certains chez nous
veulent la préserver sans rien bouger
mais ça c'est un autre débat en tout cas
comment est-ce que dans le cadre de
l'application du Zéro artificialisation
net des sols la question de communes qui
aujourd'hui peuvent être sanctionnées
parce que en quelques années elles ont
changé de statut parce que parce que
vous l'avez dit des risques inondations
etc etc et d'autres qui vont vouloir
construire ce fond et enfin je finirai
vous l'avez dit mais les projets
nationaux je pense qu'ils ne sont pas
car on voyait aux régions sur les enjeux
d'industrialisation etc moi je suis
peut-être un gars mais je crois encore
en un état protège et aménageurs et non
ce n'est pas qu'une question
décentralisation de dire les projets de
requalification et d'industrialisation
sont le fruit des régions et ne sont pas
du domaine des enjeux nationaux merci
beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur Renan
Dantec
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
tout d'abord je doute pas mon plaisir
parce que ça m'arrive pas à chaque loi
surtout pas les précédentes mais
soutenir le ministre sur un point
absolument essentiel de cette loi qui
est le 50% sur les 10 prochaines années
et ce 50% ça veut dire que même si on
essaye tous ici trouver plus de
souplesse sur l'application de cette loi
qu'on va pas créer des enveloppes qui
sont plus contenues nulle part parce que
sinon on va passer à 55 60 65 70 et à la
fin on tiendra pas l'objectif donc je
pense que là dessus notamment sur la
mutualisation des projets nationaux il
faut bien qu'à un moment il soit de
nouveau réparti et de même pour ce qu'on
pourrait
redonner pour créer de la souplesse au
territoire ruraux ça ça me semble un
point quand même absolument essentiel
sinon en fait on va au nom de la
souplesse contourner la loi une fois
qu'on a dit ça
c'est quand même une loi assez mal
phagotée je me permets de le dire à ce
stade là avec notamment le fait qu'on a
et on en a beaucoup parlé cet après-midi
dans nos auditions
une méthode sur les 10 prochaines années
et une méthode sur les 20 années qui
suivent qui n'est pas la même et sans
qu'on connaisse très bien et
Monsieur Miss vient d'en parler quel est
l'objectif quantitatif des deux
décennies qui suivent et alors je ne
sais pas quel est notre marge de
manœuvre de réécriture de la loi c'est
non pas dans le cadre de la CMP
virtuelle qui précède la loi qui est une
nouvelle manière de produire de la loi
donc on va attendre ce qui va sortir
demain mais
jusqu'où peut-on aller moi il me semble
que la base des 10 prochaines années et
probablement la bonne base qui nous
évite beaucoup de faux débats
c'est-à-dire
Hénaf pas et neuf c'est pas parce que je
suis finistérien et le pâté est produit
à Pouldreuzic que je dis ça
ça en mettra pas au courant de
rendez-vous mais
le zéro artificialisation ça veut dire
qu'on ne touche pas à ce qui est NAF et
ça veut dire que ce qui est dans
l'enveloppe urbaine quel que soit son
statut là on peut jouer avec et que et
que ça doit être la règle finalement sur
les 30 années et pas une règle
différente qui arriverait dans 10 ans ça
c'est le premier point et je trouve que
là dessus on a encore vraiment à
discuter je voudrais entendre monsieur
Miss ensuite et je fais écho à
l'audition qu'on vient d'avoir de région
de France on a un problème avec avec les
quotas tels qu'ils sont aujourd'hui le
fameux 50% ça marche pas bien on sait
tous d'abord c'est une prime à ceux qui
ont déjà
artificialisé on l'a déjà tous dit
est-ce qu'il est il n'est pas imaginable
aujourd'hui
revoir c'est pourcentage qui est
toujours un pourcentage à l'échelle de
la commune ok qui est un pourcentage qui
intègre l'effort de
non-artificialisation qu'il y a un
pourcentage régional voire qu'il y ait
aussi finalement un pourcentage national
pour que les tonnes se rajoute pas des
projets dans tous les sens moi il me
semble que c'est sur ce point-là qu'on
n'est pas très bien parti et qu'on
essaye de contourner une règle de base
qui est trop rigide et qui ne tient pas
assez compte de la diversité des
territoires parce que si on part que du
pari de l'intelligence collective et de
la mutualisation on sent tous nous sur
le terrain et que ça va pas être si
facile et donc moi je remettrai il est
encore temps en gardant le 50%, c'est ça
c'est un point d'accord avec le
gouvernement de remettre peut-être un
plat les pourcentages donc d'aller un
peu plus loin finalement que le
rapporteur et la Commission à ce stade
dans le fait d'avoir une autre règle
d'application
des 50% donc je vais pas plus loin sinon
on va être toute cette trop long mais je
pense que là il est encore temps
peut-être qu'on essaie de se mettre
d'accord après sur les différents points
de souplesse je crois qu'il y a beaucoup
d'accord entre nous et garder les
énerves c'est-à-dire on va pas se faire
de faux débat sur les jardins publics
privés fin des tas de débats qu'on est
en train de rajouter qui sont pas
nécessaire
alors je vous propose maintenant de
donner la parole à Angèle Préville
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre donc je
vous parle moi d'un territoire le lot ou
qui est très peu dense 174
000 habitants et constitué en grande
partie de communes de largement moins de
1000 habitants donc comment fait-on pour
développer un territoire comme le mien
alors qu'il y a des postes à pourvoir
qu'il y a dans pas mal de communes où
les pluies sont déjà cristallisés des
droits à construire qui vont être très
peu importante des terres agricoles qui
sont des terres pauvres des terres Ducos
par exemple et des élus qui ne
comprennent pas pourquoi il ne pourrait
pas donner des droits à construire parce
qu'il y a une demande dans mon
département dans la plupart des communes
rien à vendre rien à louer tous a
beaucoup changé suite au covid avec une
intensification des ventes des maisons
qui se vendent dans les trois semaines
et donc beaucoup de demandes donc
comment fait-on pour gérer tout cela et
puis j'ai un autre questionnement sur la
projection possible et sur les 200 000
hectares dont vous nous avez parlé de
friche sont-elles polluées ou pas
sont-elles construites ou pas comment
va-t-on compter tout ça et avec la
remarque aussi que je fais que j'ai fait
tout à l'heure à savoir que quand un
territoire un terrain est abandonné
depuis pas mal d'années au-delà de deux
ans il a aidé déjà été reconquié par la
nature il y a de la biodiversité et donc
est-ce qu'on considère que ça cela va
être à renaturer ou pas et comment on
voit les définitions fines de ces choses
là pour pas aller à l'encontre de ce
qu'on veut faire donc voilà c'est de
questionnement que j'ai et merci
si Angèle la parole est à Stéphane
sotarel
[Musique]
merci madame la présidente madame le
ministre monsieur le ministre je vais
aussi parler d'un territoire rural le
Cantal donc aussi peu dense et en fait
c'est à la fois un appel et une question
l'appel c'est effectivement merci de
d'avoir rappelé votre attachement à la
garantie rurale avec une forme qui reste
à préciser je l'ai bien entendu mais je
crois que cette attente elle est forte
parce que vous avez parlé de double
peine pour les projets nationaux mais la
double peine pour les ruraux pour des
tout petits projets là encore pire
puisque nous partons effectivement d'une
base de référence qui est quasi nulle ou
qui est très très faible en tout cas et
donc il ne serait pas acceptable que
l'artificialisation qui a
[Musique]
occupé notre pays sur essentiellement sa
métropolisation même si c'est pas
uniquement à ce niveau là aujourd'hui
soit payé donc ce serait une double
peine par les secteurs ruraux et donc il
est absolument indispensable et je crois
que là il faut un message très fort
parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a une perte de
confiance dans la parole publique à ce
titre là sur nos territoires que cette
garantie elle soit apportée je veux pas
rentrer là dans le détail et la manière
dont il faut la construire mais il sera
indispensable qu'elle soit en tout cas
bien présente ouverte à tous et qu'elle
soit simple je veux insister sur ce
point là alors je sais qu'il faut pas
que pour simplifier tomber dans Simplice
mais je crois que la bonne compréhension
relativement simple est absolument
indispensable ma deuxième ma deuxième
remarque c'est c'est sans doute de
donner effectivement une certaine
latitude et une liberté au territoire
parce que aujourd'hui nous avons des
enjeux parfois très contradictoires on
vous a saisi il y a peu de temps
monsieur le ministre sur un sujet en
lien avec la préservation de la
biodiversité et là où nous avons de la
biodiversité on a un risque
d'exploitation industrielle que l'on
combat et inversement là où nous avons
des besoins de population parce qu'on a
un effet covid comme on le connaît dans
le Lot et donc de construction
d'aménagement bien sûr d'abord à partir
de l'existant nous avons des obstacles
donc je crois que appelle à une certaine
cohérence par rapport à ses choix de
politique publique et on y est
particulièrement sensible dans les
territoires ruraux voilà je rentre pas
dans dans la technique mais c'était
surtout ce message que je voulais que
vous entendiez merci
monsieur le ministre pour répondre à ces
quatre premières questions
l'idée pour que certaines questions ne
se répètent pas que du coup j'ai
quelques minutes d'abord je veux dire de
manière extrêmement claire à Man
que je ne me défausse pas dans des
dizaines et des dizaines de réponses
j'ai fini par faire cette réponse sur le
fait que j'étais pas présent au moment
du vote j'assume pleinement pour des
quantités de raison y compris l'objectif
de diminution et de lutte contre
l'étalement urbain 2
je pense deux sur le dépôt de la PPL
qu'on se comprenne non seulement le
calendrier exigé que vous le fassiez le
sujet c'est ce que vous voulez que ça
aboutisse avant l'été et pour que ça
aboutisse avant l'été il faut forcément
que le début de dialogue avec
l'Assemblée il est lieu maintenant et
c'était sur ce processus d'arriver à un
texte à court terme que j'insistais pas
sur le principe d'aller déposer une PPL
et en plus je ne doute pas
véritablement que la volonté de ceux qui
sont dans cette commission spéciale
c'est d'arriver à des bouger
législatives c'est pas juste de secouer
le cocotier pour dire regardez on vous
oblige à faire un truc pas possible on a
essayé de le changer mais on n'a pas pu
sinon on serait pas en train d'avoir ce
dialogue et je serai pas non plus là ce
soir en train de vous répondre une fois
de plus
très rapidement la loi Cyrus est un
mauvais exemple parce que la vérité
c'est que c'est pas parce que
c'est pas zéro c'est 12000 hectares et
normalement on ne met pas les logements
sociaux sur les espaces naturels et
agricoles on a plutôt tendance à les
mettre à regarder comment la ville se
reconstruit sur elle-même
même si vous dites que ça dépend où
partir du principe que par définition on
ne reconstruit pas y compris sur des
maisons creuses sur le fait d'aller
faire évoluer un certain de logements de
centre-ville avec ce type de statut je
pense que ça relève d'une vision dans
lequel on fait porter à la loizanne
l'impossibilité de toucher les objectifs
du SRU alors que vous avez des communes
qui ont dit foncier qui ne tiennent pas
les autres objectifs et qui a des
communes qui n'ont pas de foncier qui
les tiennent donc je souhaite qu'on ne
simplifie pas trop ce sujet de la loi
SRU et pour être dans un département ou
des quantités de communes en franchi le
seuil des 5000 habitants par fusion et
se retrouvent désormais à devoir tenir
les 25% avec des formes urbaines qui ne
sont pas du tout propices à tenir les
objectifs il y a plein d'autres sujets
que le zan au titre de la loi SRU
très rapidement
je redis je suis pleinement d'accord sur
l'objectif des 50% et je pense que le
vrai sujet de dialogue et de stratégie
si il se passe quoi après
mais que la première période elle est
importante dans ce qu'elle décrit et que
je le redis 12000 hectares selon la
manière dont vous les lotissez avec les
réserves de friches qu'on a c'est pas ça
qui est à ce stade anxiogène ou
contrariant qui devrait l'être quand on
voit d'ores et déjà ce qui se passe vous
avez des disparités dans l'efficacité de
la construction qui sont considérables
troisième point sur
les 200 000 hectares de friches il y a
de tout pour être honnête ça va de la
dalle béton qui accueillait une serre
jusqu'au terrain industriel gigantesque
ou l'ancienne base aérienne et donc avec
des disparités de taille et de
localisation qui sont extrêmement
variées et donc je peux pas catégoriser
les choses et pour répondre d'un mot en
même temps à Stéphane sotarel autour du
Cantal et du Lot et de la garantie
rurale
on partage totalement l'idée qu'il faut
que le dispositif soit simple et que le
chiffre soit immédiat c'est pour ça que
le 1% ou un hectare pour moi dans les
deux cas ça permet d'avoir une règle qui
soit lisible je voudrais simplement vous
dire la chose suivante
c'est contre intuitif de penser que
c'est la métropolisation qui a accéléré
l'étalement urbain la vérité c'est que
tous les territoires y ont participé on
a un phénomène d'étalement urbain sans
logement autour des métropoles et on a
un phénomène de consommation de fonciers
avec peu d'habitants dans certaines
zones et à l'intérieur d'un département
et de la France on a des écarts avec des
territoires qui ont été sobre et
d'autres qui n'ont pas été juste pour
vous donner un chiffre qui est précis
60% de l'étalement urbain au cours de
ces 10 dernières années c'est fait en
zonage c'est détendu
5% c'est fait en a
et en B entre le B1 et le B2 vous avez
le delta
et donc dit autrement on voit bien qu'on
a des des situations qui sont pas
forcément homogènes et que ça n'est pas
parce que vous êtes sur un territoire
rural que vous n'avez pas artificialisé
il y a des endroits où c'est le cas mais
il y en a d'autres à l'inverse où il y a
plus avoir des étalons urbains sans
corrélation immédiate avec le nombre
d'habitants d'où l'idée de pas avoir une
règle aveugle et de territorialiser
parce que ce que le Parlement a fait
c'est la suite je termine c'est
c'est la convention citoyenne qui avait
dit il faut faire 50% et le Parlement a
dit on ne peut pas faire ça c'est une
mauvaise idée c'est la limite du tirage
au sort de citoyen parce que le
caractère aveugle du dispose une des
limites parce que le caractère aveugle
il conduit à ce que chacun parte de ce
qu'il est donc on va territorialiser les
enveloppes et on va faire confiance aux
régions pour être capable de déterminer
les trajectoires mais il est écrit nulle
part qu'une région donnera zéro à des
territoires ruraux on peut même dans
certains endroits se retrouver avec des
stratégies qui consisteraient deux à
donner davantage à des territoires moins
denses parce que je me permets de vous
dire qu'il y a un deuxième élément qui
est très instructif c'est de regarder
les actuels sera dettes
et vous découvrirez qu'il y a des
métropoles qui ont expliqué que elle
elle serait Lausanne dès 2040 si les
régions sur lesquelles elle se situe les
prennent au mot ça veut dire que les
réserves d'urbanisation que ça permettra
pour des territoires intermédiaires sur
important la question que je me pose
c'est est-ce que dans les semaines et
les mois qui viennent ces mêmes
territoires assumeront ensuite ce 0
artificialisation nette en avance de
phase la Bretagne disant qu'elle le fera
dès 2040 pour la totalité de son
territoire je demande à voir parce
qu'encore une fois c'est relativement
complexe à faire atterrir
oui bonjour à tous mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs donc
vous dire notre absolue
détermination à travailler en confiance
et à redonner confiance à nos mères et
quelqu'un l'une ou l'un d'entre vous a
dit
hyper de confiance moi je l'ai perçu
depuis 6 mois donc l'idée c'est de
sortir de cette réunion avec
une feuille de route une façon de
travailler pour que rapidement sur les
points sur lesquels il y a discussion
dans la PPL qui qui nous est proposé on
puisse rapidement les lever pour que
rapidement vous puissiez dire Homer que
finalement on est d'accord sur beaucoup
de choses et qu'on va travailler sur les
quelque chose qui ne sont pas encore
un consensus et que on puisse leur
donner confiance premièrement
deuxièmement je travaille à l'issue de
ces six mois avec la NCT
à l'issue de ces six mois en réalité sur
un programme d'ingénierie qui vise
accompagner nos élus locaux en ruralité
sur un sujet que vous appelez tous de
vos voeux qui est l'ingénierie
l'ingénierie pour entre autres être
capable rapidement de porter un projet
territoire comment travailler à
l'échelle d'un petit village sur un
hectare 1% si on accompagne pas nos
maires en ruralité sur le plan de
l'ingénierie donc là d'ici fin mars je
serai en mesure de vous présenter ce que
nous sommes en mesure de faire avec la
NCT pour accompagner les maires dans
leur réflexion de conduire un projet de
territoire si possible collectif si
possible à la maille de
l'intercommunalité mais pas que
pour finir la garantie rurale
telle qu'elle est proposée aujourd'hui
en contre-proposition à ce un hectare
sous la forme de 1%, je trouve que c'est
intéressant il y a plusieurs hypothèses
plusieurs
peut-être une ou deux séances de travail
à conduire mais je pense qu'on peut
trouver quelque chose qui vous convienne
et qui soit acceptable et qui nous
remettent pas en cause un certain nombre
de fondamentaux de la loi
pour laisser beaucoup de liberté au
territoire moi je vois dans certaines
régions le sera d'être révisé être
travaillé même dans la main avec les
intercos mais dans la main avec les mers
donc c'est très inégal la façon dont ce
sera d'être révisé et travailler mais il
est vrai qu'à de nombreux endroits ils
ont fait travailler les territoires qui
font des propositions il les consolide
et finalement il s'aperçoivent qu'ils
peuvent y aller surtout quand ils
portaient l'ambition d'être à 40%
en 2030 voilà merci merci Madame la
Ministre la parole est à Sonia de la
pauvreté puis à Jean-Marc Boyer et on
continue parce qu'il y a encore
quatre autres demandes de parole merci
beaucoup
ce qui se passe avec avec Lausanne c'est
que les élus sur le terrain sont face à
des quel que soit la taille de la
commune en réalité à des injonctions
contradictoires il y a certaines
missions qui nous paraissent impossibles
entre les objectifs prioritaires dans un
certain nombre de domaines et notamment
de l'environnement et du développement
durable pour n'évoquer que celui-là mais
aussi en termes de de logement politique
en matière de développement économique
et tout ça ça vient percuter
l'idéal par la réalité la réalité de
l'application et le zanne la difficulté
c'est que à la fois il n'est pas
compréhensible et il est vécu comme un
élément de de perte de solidarité par
les territoires ruraux parce que c'est
vraiment comme ça que c'est c'est vécu
et vous le savez bien c'est vraiment là
que c'est c'est mal vécu avec un enjeu
qui transcende tout cela qui me
semble-t-il et l'enjeu démocratique et
donc il y a vraiment un intérêt j'allais
dire majeur à ce que la parole de l'État
soit clair sur les objectifs parce que
l'objectif Zam ça doit pas être
contradictoire avec l'objectif de
biodiversité de tram vertébré ça doit
pas être contradictoire avec la
construction de logements avec
l'application la loi SRU dans des
communes nouvelles qui sont des qui
émargent à la SRU maintenant qui sont le
regroupement de plusieurs communes
rurales et qui se trouve donc confrontés
à la construction de logements social
sur des terres agricoles donc ça existe
ça existe et c'est vraiment c'est un
sujet qui est montant et majeur et sur
lequel pour l'instant les sujets n'ont
pas été traités avec territoires
d'industrie et France 2030 qui demande à
ce qui est vraiment d'une grande
ambition économique et notamment une
installation de giga Factory et de
structures industrielles innovantes qui
demandent beaucoup de consommation
foncière et qui pour le coup sont
d'intérêt national parce que Porter a
accompagné largement par la contribution
de l'État et quand on parle de grosse
structures économiques ou par exemple
sans parler d'économie d'un réacteur
comme PANI derrière c'est des logements
et des logements à construire pour
accompagner les ingénieurs tous les
techniciens qui travaillent sur site etc
etc donc il y a pas que l'emprise
foncière du projet lui-même il y a tout
le reste qui qui va avec et puis pour
pour clore sur ce sujet dire qu'à un
moment il va falloir que l'État se
mettent en heures de marche pour dire
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de la logistique
par exemple la logistique c'est très
consommateur de fonciers mais on sait
que derrière il y a un gros enjeu en
matière de développement durable et de
bilan carbone parce que c'est la du
dernier kilomètre qui peut être moins
carbonée qu'elle ne les mais tout ça ça
s'organise et ça consomme du foncier
donc à un moment les injonctions
deviennent tellement complexes que les
élus ne savent même pas à quoi ils vont
avoir droit mais savent qu'ils sont
obligés de faire un tas de choses qui ne
vont pas pouvoir faire et donc la
difficulté c'est pas que
que de régler cette question c'est qu'il
faut savoir ce qui est prioritaire
quasiment commune par commune et puis le
deuxième sujet c'est celui de l'après
comme vous l'avez dit justement zéro
artificialisation nette qu'est-ce qu'on
met dans le net c'est quoi la
renaturation où on en est dans la
réflexion pour les critères de
renaturation qu'est-ce qu'on redonne à
la nature est-ce que si on des
imperméabilise c'est déjà pas déjà un
gros pas de gagner de gagner et donc ce
sujet là il va falloir y répondre
quasiment en même temps parce que les
disons on va y arriver à trouver des
enveloppes puis on pense à être
compliqué si chacun fait sa part faut
conclure mais derrière on a vraiment à
répondre sur cette question du net parce
que les villes solidaire des territoires
heureux qu'à partir du moment où on sait
ce qu'il y a derrière la renaturation
merci Sonia Jean-Marc Goyer oui merci
madame la Présidente merci monsieur le
ministre
je crois qu'aujourd'hui
les maires ruraux
ont une double une double inquiétude la
première à travers l'intercommunalité
les maires des petites communes rurales
se sentent un peu marginalisé un peu
oublié je dirais même beaucoup parfois
et surtout donc il y a un problème de
confiance c'est un problème de prise de
responsabilité
et si on enlève cette prise de
responsabilité au maire de la commune je
veux dire il va vraiment plus lui rester
grand chose déjà que il en reste pas
grand chose alors je vais faire simple
dans la PPL qui est proposé
il a été travaillé le minimum d'un
hectare d'avoir une mise à disposition
d'un hectare pas commune vous proposez
1% si j'ai bien compris sur les surfaces
déjà urbanisées on a eu cet après-midi
l'audition de
des représentants de l'Île-de-France
très intéressantes où en Île-de-France
il y a effectivement énormément de
demandes de logement
une crise de logements très importante
c'est ce que nous a été expliqué
mais en même temps
il y a aussi un dispositif de 1% avec un
minimum d'un hectare
alors cette solution enfin moi elle m'a
paru
intéressante parce que elle permet
d'avoir d'un côté le 1% que vous
souhaitez et que que vos argumentez mais
d'un autre côté d'avoir le un hectare
pour les communes rurales et j'ai senti
que cette disposition elle allait dans
le sens et qu'elle pouvait satisfaire
les communes rurales je voudrais savoir
ce que vous en pensez
parce qu'on fait 1% avec un minimum d'un
état pour les communes rurales
si Jean-Marc Christian Redon sarrazi
le ministre je voulais évoquer le sujet
de la souveraineté plus particulièrement
la souveraineté industrielle
j'avais présidé une mission du Sénat sur
l'innovation et donc où on avait conclu
que il y avait un impératif de
l'industrialisation alors que ce soit
pour le retour de l'industrie qui était
parti ou pour conserver des des
industries innovantes afin qu'elles ne
parte pas hors sur ce qui est tombé je
connais sur une tendance sur les 10 ans
passés on était plutôt sur une tendance
à la délocalisation c'est à dire à une
moindre consommation d'espace si on veut
inverser si on veut réfléchir cette
tendance
c'est peut-être pas la bonne solution
que de regarder ce qui s'est passé ce
qu'on n'a pas fait de bien pendant 10
ans
pour essayer pour le reproduire sur des
dizaines à venir donc il ne faudrait-il
pas sur ce sujet là une approche
particulière pour tout simplement
revenir vers une souveraineté
industrielle notamment donc sur tout ce
qui relève de des nouvelles technologies
enfin voilà tous les sujets que vous
avez laissés du côté des régions
ce qui peut poser problème ensuite en
termes d'émergence de projet nouveau
merci
Eric et rouge
quand on regarde l'objectif
du zan on oublie souvent de le croiser
avec celui de la population et en fait
la population française va augmenter de
manière moins que proportionnelle par
rapport à la période qu'on a connu
précédemment on devrait je vérifie
encore devoir arriver à 69 millions
d'habitants à peu près en 2050 bien
entendu ces projections sont toujours
Suzette bon voilà on sait mais néanmoins
on a une tendance donc la question du
zan c'est pas tant une question de
limite j'allais dire quantitative et
d'expansion c'est plutôt une question de
distribution en fonction des différences
territoriales
et la difficulté dont on parle c'est que
on applique une même règle je voulais
déjà dire des territoires qui sont à des
territoires qui sont différents puisque
la trajectoire démographique de
l'ensemble
des différents départements français
sont très disbles on a des territoires
en déprime on a des territoires en
emprise
ceux qui sont en emprise subissent la
double peine ceux qui sont des prises
l'ont déjà subi d'une certaine d'une
certaine façon et là moi je sais pas je
sais pas comment on fait dans la dans la
différenciation parce que même dans la
différenciation au sein d'une région il
s'avère qu'il y a des régions qui sont
sensiblement plus attractives que les
autres et qui vont avoir des difficultés
supplémentaires par rapport à d'autres
justement parce que c'est l'ensemble de
leur territoire qui est attractif donc
là je sais pas comment on fait sur les
territoires littoraux on en a parlé je
ne sais pas comment on fait non plus
avec avec la rareté avec la rareté du du
foncier est-ce qu'il faut imaginer dans
ce cas là
des différences de traitement en termes
de typologie est-ce que on fait on
estime qu'une résidence secondaire il y
a il y a une surcotte pour Lausanne
parce que on doit privilégier des
logements
à l'année
dernière point vous avez parlé des 200
000 hectares de friches
sauf que je postule encore une fois
d'après la trajectoire industrielle de
la France que c'est friche ne sont pas
réparties de manière équivalente sur
l'ensemble du territoire français et que
elle concerne plus particulièrement des
territoires qui a priori n'auront pas
besoin de la plus grande extension à
l'avenir
comment résoudre cette petite difficulté
parce qu'un chiffre en tant que tel
c'est
un stock théorique
le problème c'est la distribution de ce
socle théorique
je me suis rendu
c'est Anne Catherine merci Madame la
présence madame messieurs et ministre en
fait moi je vais rebondir un peu sur la
dernière intervention parce que en fait
je pense qu'il y a effectivement
beaucoup de disparité dans nos
territoires et que la difficulté
aujourd'hui c'est d'appliquer un
principe voilà zan national pour de
l'équité mais sur un sur des territoires
qui n'ont absolument pas les mêmes
réalités les mêmes réalités et c'est je
pense ce qui inquiète beaucoup nos élus
qui sont en fait accablés par le fait
qu'ils ont déjà des contraintes
nombreuses à respecter et que là on va
leur impliquer un un supplément de de
contraintes nationales moi juste
rebondir monsieur ministre tout à
l'heure vous évoquiez ces territoires
soudains qui ne connaissent pas
d'évolution démographique à la hausse et
pourtant on construit moi ce que
j'observe par exemple dans les
territoires comme le mien mais c'est
effectivement largement dû à des
résidences secondaires nos concitoyens
qui vivent en ville Souha avoir une
belle résidence secondaire spacieuse et
puis on entend aussi souvent les mers
qui nous disent combien ils sont
aujourd'hui confrontés à des besoins par
rapport à une cellule familiale qui
explose avant il fallait un logement
maintenant il en faut deux donc en fait
le problème c'est de faire cet exercice
de fiction alors qu'on ne connaît pas
complètement les évolutions quand même
société et des mœurs de nos concitoyens
et donc ça ça repousse la question en
fait de la gouvernance des stradettes la
gouvernance d'un
âne de proximité qui va devoir évoluer
aussi avec les réalités ce territoire et
moi par rapport à la au sujet de la
garantie rurale je voulais juste vous
rappeler madame et monsieur le ministre
je sais pas si vous l'avez à l'esprit et
en tout cas à savoir ce que vous en
pensez en Bourgogne Franche-Comté je
l'avais déjà évoqué en fait le stradette
a gardé une enveloppe de réserve
qui aurait vocation en fait à être
répartie dans les communes où il n'y
aurait pas de potentiel suffisant et qui
serait laissée en fait à l'appréciation
alors conférence des scottes ou avoir
quel instance voilà je m'interroge
j'avoue que j'ai pas plus analyser
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas la les pistes en
fait d'une souplesse et d'une adaptation
territoriale
à des réalités qui sont quand même assez
diverses et qui vont en plus évoluer
dans le temps merci
à pardon merci Anne-Catherine monsieur
Gold et Monsieur Vial merci Madame
abrévidente madame la ministre monsieur
ministre moi je avec les différentes
auditions qu'on a eu aujourd'hui je me
pose la question de savoir si finalement
on est dans les conséquences de la loi
krima climat et résilience ou si on est
tout simplement pas dans les dans les
symptômes de la loi neutre la loi de
Camille accent sur big is beautiful et
l'aménagement du territoire qui est
passé après via les documents
d'urbanisme finalement les mers ont été
dessaisies de la gestion de leur de leur
territoire donc aujourd'hui je crois que
ce qu'il faudrait essayer d'apporter
c'est une correction une correction par
rapport à notamment comment on remet les
mers au centre des décisions en matière
de gestion de leur territoire parce
qu'on le on l'a vu on voit les
difficultés qu'il y a pour les mers les
plus ruraux d'intégrer
lorsqu'il lorsque les EPCI avaient pas
cette taille là il faisait tous partie
du bureau tout c'était investi tout ça
avait une mission particulière
aujourd'hui on les voit quand même un
peu à la peine je pense que la garantie
rurale est certainement un outil pour
remettre les mères justement et les
meilleurs ruraux au centre des décisions
eux qui se sentent évidemment
dessaisides de la gestion de leur
territoire
merci Monsieur
le Ministre tout d'abord merci d'avoir
choisi cette salle dans laquelle on n'a
pas l'habitude de nous demander la
commission culture de se réunir et je
regarde depuis tout à l'heure le tableau
qui est au-dessus des ministres et je
trouve qu'il est parfaitement en
adéquation avec avec les débats que nous
avons depuis tout à l'heure c'est pas
lui neuve c'est pas lunaire alors c'est
pas un ballon espion non plus sinon le
sort qu'on lui réservé c'est pas le même
mais en tous les cas je pense que les
maires dont on parlait à l'instant sont
un peu satellisées et on a l'impression
des fois d'avoir un objet non identifié
avec ces nouvelles loisan j'ai un autre
point commun avec vous monsieur le
ministre c'est moi non plus j'ai pas
voté cette cette loi vous étiez mais je
savais pas au moment où j'ai voté compte
je n'avais pas à quel point j'aurai
raison
et je m'en aperçois de plus en plus
j'avais un problème d'organisation que
je voulais vous soumettre et puis une
interrogation sur un propos vous avez
tenu tout à l'heure on a créé un objet
en termes d'urbanisme management du
territoire en cas de dimension ça peut
être la loi 4D plutôt que la loizan
puisque aujourd'hui
on avait déjà une organisation verticale
entre le stradette les PLU et les
scottes et les PLU sans parler de tous
les schémas
orthogonaux qu'on peut avoir les les
chartes de parc etc qui viennent se
rajouter on a les scottes avaient déjà
une mis un peu soucoupe réglé les PLU
pour avoir une vision globale et rendue
interdépendant finalement les pluies au
sein de ce Scott là avec cette
organisation et cette gestion sous forme
d'enveloppes d'enveloppes définies qu'il
faut se répartir comme une part de
gâteau on est en train de lier les
scottes entre eux
et les scottes deviennent
interdépendants entre eux au sein du
sera d'être comme les PLU sont
interdépendants au sein au sein d'un
Scott mais alors on apprend ça en
technologie on apprenait son 6ème on
apprendra ça en 5e à partir de l'année
prochaine
quand on a un objet qui est qui est lié
verticalement et horizontalement dès que
ça bouge un peu ça casse il y a pas un
peu de souplesse si on y met pas un peu
des joints et là c'est la souplesse on
la trouve pas
et on se retrouve confronté à des
situations
inextricables avec un système qui
fonctionne pas pour ouvrir vous lister
on a commencé à vous lister toutes les
situations dans lesquelles on va être
confronté à des situations qui qui ne
marchent pas et le système nous empêche
de de prendre en compte ces situations
vous vous le savez que comme presque
nous tous ici on a tous été maire ou
président de la terre communalité
l'urbanisme c'est à la fois de la
planification et de l'opportunité il
faut être capable aussi d'avoir une
souplesse de répondre à des opportunités
comment fait-on aujourd'hui quand on
accueille un projet d'intérêt alors
qu'il soit d'intérêt national régional
peu importe où locale si pour pouvoir
l'accueillir il faut modifier le PLU le
scotch le stradette ça devient
impossible on va on va acheter on va
construire dans à l'étranger dans les
pour ceux qui sont limitrophes comme moi
on y fera en Italie ou mais on pourra
plus construire en France vous disiez
que l'objectif il était aussi en termes
écologique mais on sait que
en réindustrialisant c'est comme ça
qu'on que c'est en produisant en local
qu'on évite les frais de déplacement et
c'est comme ça qu'on va lutter le plus
aussi contre contre
le réchauffement climatique on va
s'empêcher de pouvoir faire ça et et
avec des injonctions nationales qui
viennent du coup dans des objets
d'urbanisme qui sont liés les uns aux
autres
ces injonctions on va rendre plus
difficile dans les taux de territoire
tendus de la situation et on va on va
aggraver accélérer cette tension dans
les étoiles tendus on va condamner
certains territoires fragiles on fait
des programmes PVD etc c'est bien
d'avoir des vitrines très attractives de
refaire les façades les aménagements
urbains ils ont besoin de clients les
commerces les écoles dans ces communes
rurales elles ont besoin d'enfants et
c'est eux qu'on doit ramener avant de
mettre de l'argent pour refaire les
façades c'est très bien de faire ça mais
si à côté de ça on peut pas gérer le
développement local sur ces territoires
qui en ont spécifiquement besoin on va
là encore droit dans le mur et injuste
pour des territoires qui ont fait des
efforts enfin moi j'en ai territoire de
montagne je suis sénateur de la Savoie
depuis 1985 on fait plus nous de on est
limité parlait de rondé par la loi
montagne attentive justement à
construire uniquement en proximité etc
je conclus excusez-moi donc
c'est aussi profondément et le seul
point sur lequel je voulais si vous
permettez revenir sur ce que vous avez
dit c'est sur les projets d'intérêt
nationaux qui seront pas nationaux parce
que ils seront forcément pris au niveau
local quand ils sont industriels ou
autre comment expliquer vous que le
président Macron soit venu récemment en
Isère j'en parlais tout à l'heure
annoncé un projet industriel avec 1000
nouveaux emplois et c'était
microélectronics un projet phare qu'on
pensait tous d'international moi par
principe nous dit celui-là il est
d'intérêt National c'est même le
président de la République qui est venu
l'annoncer il a pas consulter les
scottes avant de venir l'annoncer il a
pas consulter les communes qui vont
devoir accueillir les 1000 personnes sur
leur territoire sur leur quotas avant de
venir annoncer est-ce que ça veut dire
que demain le président de la République
devra consulter la CTAP l'estradettes et
les scottes avant de faire une annonce
industrielle d'envergure pour le
territoire est-ce qu'il s'y engage ou
est-ce que des projets comme celui-ci on
peut quand même considérer où est-ce que
le lion Turin on peut considérer que ces
projets si un jour vous décidez de qu'il
faudra faire des accès pour rejoindre le
tunnel qu'on est en train de percer
est-ce qu'on pourra considérer que c'est
un enjeu national merci Madame et
Monsieur le Ministre et si je peux me
permettre avant de vous donner la parole
monsieur le ministre dire que et un
article des échos qui vient de paraître
et qui mis en avant la vallée de
l'électromobilité dans la région des
Hauts de France avec un ensemble de
gigafactory assez considérable lié aussi
au Grand Port autonome de Dunkerque à la
présence du sel norcière qui est une
stratégie on est dans au cœur de
l'Europe du Nord et c'est ce qui lit
effectivement le Bassin parisien et qui
ouvre donc on y a posé l'ensemble des
gigafactory et on ne parle pas de ce
qu'il y a autour les infras le logement
mais je ne suis pas sûr que le président
du conseil régional et idées à ce jour
que on envisage pas sur des projets
d'intérêts européens décidée pour
essayer d'avoir notre autonomie en
matière de véhicule électrique demain je
suis pas sûr que tout ça se soit très
clair et en tout cas monsieur le
ministre il y a une forte volonté de
tous les territoires d'accompagner cette
mutation écologique de notre industrie
il faut quand même prévenir les élus qui
s'engagent à fond là-dedans de ce qui
les attend sur ces grands projets
industriels et donc si vous pouviez nous
donner aussi la les éléments
d'information si
qui concrètement et comme l'a dit Cédric
aussi sur des projets de grande
envergure on considère que c'est un
projet privé et que ça ne relève pas de
l'intérêt national on va avoir des gros
sujets
l'étalement urbain est mauvais pour le
climat il est mauvais pour les
biodiversité
à fur et à mesure qu'on avance dans
cette discussion et qu'on commence à
regarder tout ce qu'on va se priver de
faire en artificialisant on finit quand
même par oublier le point de départ
on peut le remettre en cause on peut
considérer qu'après tout la trajectoire
d'artificialisation n'est pas
incompatible et qui a d'autres priorités
mais en entendant la somme de tous les
arguments qui sont employés par les uns
et les autres
je tiens à vous dire que le sujet à la
fin c'est quelle trajectoire on se donne
et si on part du principe qui a des
choses qui parce qu'elles sont
importantes doivent être sortis de la
trajectoire d'artificialisation ça veut
dire qu'il faudra qu'on soit capable de
coefficienter la place qu'on donne à la
biodiversité et à la lutte contre les
règlements climatiques contenu de tous
les constats qui peuvent exister sur ce
point
moi dans ce que j'entends ce soir
il y a des choses dans lesquelles je me
retrouve et ensuite je pense qu'il y a
des prophéties auto-réalisatrices ou des
sujets qui méritent d'être travail
je pourrais répondre à Monsieur VIAL
je salue la cohérence que je ne peux pas
croire que son souhait se soit que ce
soit par la venue du président de la
République qu'un grand projet soit dans
mercure national et si je m'amuse à
renverser l'argumentation qu'il a fait
ça aboutirait à considérer que c'est par
le fait du prince qui est un projet
considé doit être considéré comme étant
hors artificialisation parce qu'il a la
validation du président de la République
ou du président de Région personne
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
j'apprécie l'exercice qui consiste à me
faire chahuter j'apprécie simplement
vous me permettiez de vous répondre sur
la tonalité avec laquelle vous êtes
adressé à moi et donc je dis de manière
extrêmement claire que en caricaturant
la façon dont nous défendons ce qui nous
semble être un point d'équilibre et
d'atterrissage à la fois entre ce qui a
été souhaité et ce qui est souhaitable
demain je pense pas qu'on fasse
progresser la cause de la construction
qu'on a souhaité
ça a été dit par Sonia d'après voté oui
il y a des injonctions contradictoires
parce qu'on est aujourd'hui dans une
situation que aucune génération avant
nous n'a connu et qui consiste à
regarder comment décarbones avec je vous
le dis de manière très simple mais un
coup
de notre retard à agir sur un certain
nombre de sujets climatiques qui se
retournera contre ceux qu'on prétendante
ce soir
l'adaptation au changement climatique
avec une augmentation de température qui
est liée au fait qu'on se préoccupe pas
d'éviter les îlots de chaleur de demain
quand il s'agira de la payer après
demain et qu'on se retournera vers les
acteurs de proximité on aura à ce moment
là un débat pour savoir comment on
organise et si ce sont des projets qui
ont été rendus possibles maintenant là
la question de notre responsabilité elle
sera posée sur la responsabilité des
maires
d'abord
si on regarde les chiffres au cours de
ces 10 dernières années il y a 15000
communes dans ce pays qui ont consommé
moins de deux hectares
pour revenir à l'histoire de la garantie
du 1 ha
et qu'un système de double cliquet qui
consisterait à dire c'est 1% avec un
plancher de un hectare fait forcément
plus que un hectare ou un pour cent
puisqu'on ajoute deux règles et donc que
ça veut dire que la part qu'on ça c'est
pour répondre à la question votre voisin
qui est parti monsieur Boyer je crois
qui m'avait interrogé sur le fait de
cumuler les deux dispositifs le cumul
des deux dispositifs revient à renforcer
chacun des deux il ne revient pas à
rendre le dispositif alternatif et il
nous conduirait sur une trajectoire
d'artificialisation figée non
répartissable sur la base des dynamiques
territoriales qui seraient plus élevées
j'ajoute que pour rester sur ce point la
question c'est encore une fois pourquoi
faire
dans les années 70 on gagnait de la
population et on s'est retrouvé avec des
modèles économiques qui nous ont poussés
à consommer du foncier pour des choses
que nous ne ferions pas aujourd'hui
personne n'imagine demain faire de
grandes zones commerciales de périphérie
avec des magasins d'usine sur des
surfaces aussi importantes que celles
qu'on a connu par le passé
à la fois parce qu'il y a une
concurrence virtuelle qui s'est
développée qui a entraîné d'autres types
aujourd'hui de besoins et le combat du
moment c'est effectivement que
l'artificialisation elle soit synonyme
d'accueil de population en termes de
logements ou d'accueil de
réindustrialisation du pays
et si on s'amuse à faire des soldes il
faut aussi regarder ce qu'on va faire en
moins et ce qu'on a appris au cours de
ces dernières années collectivement pas
nous chacun de nos territoires prenez
les zones d'activités les zones
industrielles qui sont présentes dans
vos départements comparer celles qui ont
été faites il y a 30 ans et celles qui
sont faites aujourd'hui et vous
apercevrez à quel point sans âme la
plupart des élus ont commencé à se
demander comment faire en sorte de
rationaliser le foncier pour que
l'espace qui soit pris au monde agricole
sur le moins élevé possible et donc les
pentes dont nous sommes en train de
discuter elles ne sont absolument pas à
la hauteur de ce qu'on a en train de
décrire c'est à dire le fait que tout à
coup ne pourrait plus rien faire
alors il y a eu ce phénomène de désintus
réalisation qui a conduit à se retrouver
avec des friches
oui mais
si vous regardez c'est malheureusement
pas des projets industriels ou même des
projets avec beaucoup d'emplois qui ont
le plus artificialisé au cours de ces 30
dernières années on s'est retrouvé avec
une décorrélation des trajectoires
d'artificialisation et de création de
richesse ou d'accueil de population
il faut qu'on soit basique et simple
pour reprendre les propos de Cécile
Ramon sur certains aspects je ne pense
pas que la résidence secondaire côté
d'une certaine manière ce soit une bonne
idée parce que
ça devient imaginer que ça change de
statut dans quelques années comment je
recalculerai les trajectoires
d'artificialisation en fonction de la
situation dans laquelle je me suis
retrouvé il faut qu'on évite de
complexifier les textes et il peut y
avoir de bonnes intentions mais qui
aboutissent à des choses qui sont plus
complexes est-ce que notre intérêt
collectif c'est pas de limiter aussi
l'artificialisation là où elle est déjà
très élevée parce que quand on parle de
trajectoire où il y a une pression sur
littoral mais en partant de ce principe
on s'est retrouvé
historiquement pour voter une loi
littorale on considérant qu'à un moment
si on laissait seulement la pression
foncière s'appliquer on finirait par
avoir des Molly une partie de nos
paysages et donc en quelque sorte il y a
une prolongation dans des espaces que
nous n'étions pas habitués comme
considéré comme des richesses de
préservation de ces espaces on en
mesurant l'intérêt qu'il y aura pour
demain et après-demain pour garder un
air pur pour avoir des espaces dans
lesquels les nappes phréatiques peuvent
surcharger qui nous permettent de
limiter une partie des sécheresses que
nous connaissons et qui nous permettent
de stocker une partie de la chaleur que
nous aurons demain et à la lumière de ça
les bienfaits de ces espaces naturels et
agricoles on ne les voit pas
suffisamment aujourd'hui au quotidien
dans les discussions que nous avons
vous avez évoqué très vite le fait de
savoir si finalement on n'était pas dans
l'aboutissement d'une procédure
d'intercommunalisation qui finissait
aussi par provoquer une forme de
désespérance des élus
le territoriaux et en allant plus loin
de regarder comment
au travers de tout ça
je veux vous dire deux choses
1 il y a déjà aujourd'hui à l'échelle
des scottes des pratiques qui sont pas
du tout comparables d'un territoire à
l'autre et même des plus et avec des
communes qui sont plus ou moins bien
traitées par leurs intercommunalités je
rejoins une partie de la réflexion du
sénateurvial sur l'intérêt entre
guillemets de créer un intercost parce
que si on s'était amusé au cours de ces
dernières années additionner des Scots
voisins pour savoir quelle était la
trajectoire de population du département
on se serait rendu compte que tout le
monde s'imagine plus beau à terme que ce
qu'il est pour de vrai et que la plupart
du temps ne consomme pas ce qu'on met
sur la table c'est logique puisqu'on est
aussi dans une forme de précaution qui
consiste à dire si je me retrouve avec
un projet important ou avec quelque
chose d'inattendu il faut que j'ai la
soupape pour pouvoir l'accueillir et je
crois à je crois à la souplesse et je
crois la soupape mais je ne crois pas au
fait que avec un dispositif de
précaution généralisée qui fait qu'on
irait prendre des espaces au monde
agricole même sans en avoir besoin on
s'en sort mieux comment on construit la
soupape
d'abord il peut y avoir un lien entre la
réindustrialisation et les grands
projets d'envergure national qui
pourrait être les oies
les opérations d'intérêt national qui
sont un type de classement qui
permettrait à ce moment-là d'avoir un
processus objectif
qui s'inscrivent dans les trajectoires
dont nous décrivons qui soit une
procédure de labellisation par l'État
qui soit pas un tampon qu'on donne sur
un projet qui est prévu ça existe déjà
on pourrait imaginer faire en sorte de
l'élargir et vous ne m'avez pas
questionné sur ce que j'entends dans les
grands projets d'envergure national mais
je vais le préciser évidemment les LGV
et les bretelles d'accès de clgv sont
par définition des grands projets
d'envergure national comme toutes les
infrastructures globalement qui
permettent du transport ou de la
décarbonation évidemment des centrales
nucléaires qui sont nécessaires elles
doivent être dans ce compter à part des
projets portés par le ministère de la
Justice en particulier de construction
de prison il faut évidemment qu'on les
compte à part parce qu'il y a déjà
souvent des oppositions et des limites
proximité donc il faut pas le rajouter
en revanche sur un projet économique il
est aussi souhaitable qui est une
émulation entre territoires
et que plusieurs puissent faire des
propositions à un groupe pour accueillir
cette giga Factory dans de bonnes
conditions et dans ce contexte si on a
un dispositif qui n'est pas de les
sortir de manière systématique ou de
leur donner un tampon et à label mais
qu'on est dans un dispositif de
labellisation hautaine je pense qu'on
est capable de toucher les deux
objectifs en même temps que ça peut être
une piste qui nous permettrait de nous
retrouver et de faire en sorte que les
deux thématiques puissent faire en sorte
d'aboutir ensemble enfin
oui les friches ne sont pas réparties
partout au même endroit
et par définition elles sont dans les
territoires qui ont le plus subi la
désindustrialisation
la vraie logique de rationalisation
foncière ce serait aussi de regarder
comment on peut fléchir des projets vers
ces territoires qui ont le plus perdu
parce que si je reviens quelques
instants mesdames et messieurs à la
sagesse de nos anciens
y compris pour sauvegarder une classe le
premier réflexe c'est plutôt de demander
comment toutes les maisons du bourg sont
pleines plutôt que de se dire qu'il faut
qu'on rajoute des maisons à l'extérieur
et c'est ce que n'importe quelle mer
fait le souci évident de nos anciens y
compris pour soutenir même si il y avait
pas de loi Grenelle et de dispositif
leur commerçants c'était de penser que
c'était mieux si les maisons étaient les
moins loin possible des commerces de
manière à pouvoir soutenir aussi ses
gestes et cette raréfaction de la
consommation foncière c'est ce à quoi on
a tourné le dos en allant faire des
maisons dont on peut faire le tour très
espacées qu'on peut par joindre son
véhicule ça correspond à un modèle et à
des dispositifs qui dans certains
territoires peuvent avoir un sens mais
penser qu'on va continuer sur cette
pente et sur ce rythme dans les années
qui viennent alors qu'on a des besoins
de faire effectivement en sorte de se
retrouver de faire preuve de sobriété
sur les matériaux qu'on utilise sur les
bilans globaux que nous utilisons et sur
les fonciers pour préserver les qualités
de nos sols je pense qu'il y a des
marges et des équilibres et qu'à la fin
il y a nettement moins part sur les
objectifs et sur les ambitions que sur
les exemples que nous sommes capables de
prendre et qui nous éloignent de ces
différents éléments
donc
vous savez tout ou presque vous savez
l'état d'esprit très précis qui est le
nôtre de faire en sorte pour de vrai sur
ces sujets de pousser à ce qui est un
texte qui aboutisse au Sénat et à
l'Assemblée un bouger législative global
le sujet ensuite c'est quels moyens on
se donne pour vraiment avoir un texte
qui permette une CMP conclusive un vote
dans les mêmes termes et qui permet
effectivement de donner de la souplesse
en gardant l'objectif
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur est-ce que vous
souhaitez avant de conclure
cette longue audition donner un dernier
message
peut-être sur les
peut-être pour la route pour remercier
de nouveau tous les deux nos deux
ministres et
on est très preneur de ce travail que
vous voulez proposer de navettes sur ces
deux dispositions assez cruciales pour
le texte à venir qui est le stade le
sort du stradette
et encore une fois est-ce qu'on peut
mettre du règlement et y voir de la
prise en compte au lieu de la
compatibilité par exemple
qu'est-ce qui serait un plan B et
deuxièmement monsieur le monsieur le
ministrement pour terminer là mais donc
merci pour les éléments que nous aurons
très rapidement concernant le 1% et
c'est simulations
à la commune mais par exemple un rapide
calcul mais je ne réouvre pas du tout
les débats les communes potences est
très peu dense ça s'appelle des communes
rurales
voilà il y en a 30 000 7775 si on part
sur l'hectare avec notre disposition
c'est 30700 hectares qui sont impactés
ils sont part avec la vôtre position 1%
c'est 22 000 hectares donc les communes
rurales ne bénéficient pas alors sauf à
considérer qu'il était dynamique
territoriales ce que vous évoquez c'est
ça qu'il faudrait d'expertiser donc
c'est le deuxième point de navette je
pense
utile pour notre commission spéciale le
soir du stratège et ça on puisse
vraiment confronter voilà voilà c'est ça
c'est pas le plafond mais bien sûr
mais si on pouvait parce que une
commission c'est lourd à organiser et
vos auditions aussi faire la navette sur
ces deux points spécifiques vraiment ça
nous aiderait beaucoup je sais pas ce
que vous en pensez tout et tous vraiment
voilà
et bien écoutez sur ces mots conclusifs
de notre rapporteur un grand merci
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
et bon courage et puis on vous dit à
bientôt pour continuer les travaux allez
merci à bientôt